wonder why it's so hard to kill a
cockroach
cockroaches bodies are built to compress
though about nine millimeters tall they
can squeeze through a crack of just
three millimeters barely slowing down
their 60 centimeter per second speed as
they wriggle through researchers
measured as compressibility by filming
these insects is escaped from containers
with ever narrower slits I also showed
that Roche bodies can withstand 900
times their old wat without sustaining
any damage using the practically
unstoppable cockroach as a model they
built a six-legged robot called cram
like the cockroach it has an outer shell
consisting of moveable hard plates and
the l-shaped legs have spines on them
that enable the legs to get traction
even when they are splayed out from
being compressed at maximum the small
robot can be compressed into a space
half it's 75 millimeter height when
somewhat compressed as pictured here the
roboroach can travel 14 centimeters a
second an order of magnitude faster than
robotic worms and other soft robots
researchers are already testing larger
robots for disaster search-and-rescue
operations
but these cockroach BOTS can crawl
through spaces one-tenth the size that
existing BOTS can so at last this
built-in squish ability can be used for
something other than sneaking into
kitchens
[Music]